an object is moving along a line the
following graph gives the object's
velocity over time for each point on the
graph is the object speeding up slowing
down or neither so pause this video and
see if you can figure that out
all right now let's do it together and
first we just make we need to make sure
we're reading this carefully because
they're not asking is the velocity
increasing decreasing or neither they're
saying is the object speeding up slowing
down or neither so they're talking about
speed which is the magnitude of velocity
you could think of it as the absolute
value of velocity especially when we're
thinking about it in one dimension here
so even though they're not asking about
velocity i'm actually going to answer
both so that we can see how sometimes
they move together velocity and speed
but sometimes they might one might be
increasing while the other might be
decreasing so if we look at this point
right over here where our velocity is
two meters per second the speed is the
absolute value of velocity which would
also be two meters per second and we can
see that the slope of the velocity time
graph is positive and so our velocity is
increasing and the absolute value of our
velocity which is speed is also
increasing a moment later our velocity
might be 2.1 meters per second and our
speed would also be 2.1 meters per
second that seems intuitive enough and
we get the other scenario if we go to
this point right over here our velocity
is still positive but we see that our
velocity time graph is now downward
sloping
so our velocity is decreasing because of
that downward slope and the absolute
value of our velocity is also decreasing
right at that moment our speed is 2
meters per second and then a moment
later it might be 1.9 meters per second
all right now let's go to this point
so this point is really interesting
here we see that our velocity the slope
of the tangent line is still negative so
our velocity is still decreasing but
what about the absolute value of our
velocity which is speed
well if you think about it a moment
before this we were slowing down to get
to a zero velocity and a moment after
this we're going to be speeding up to
start having negative velocity you might
say wait speeding up for negative
velocity remember speed is the absolute
value so if your velocity goes from zero
to negative one meters per second your
speed just went from zero to one meter
per second so we're slowing down here
and we're speeding up here but right at
this moment neither is happening we are
neither speeding up nor slowing down
now what about this point
here
are the slope of our velocity time graph
or the slope of the tangent line is
still negative so our velocity is still
decreasing but what about speed
well our velocity has become is already
negative and it's becoming more negative
so the absolute value of velocity which
is 2 meters per second that is
increasing at that moment in time so our
speed is actually increasing so notice
here you see a difference
now what about this point
well the slope of the tangent line here
of our velocity time graph is zero right
at that point so that means that our
velocity is not changing so you could
say velocity
not
changing
and if speed is the absolute value or
the magnitude of velocity well that will
also be not changing so we would say
speed is i'll just say neither slowing
down or nor speeding up
last but not least this point right over
here the slope of the tangent line is
positive so our velocity is increasing
what about speed well the speed here is
two meters per second remember it would
be the absolute value of the velocity
and here and the absolute value is
actually going down if we forward in
time a little bit so our speed is
actually decreasing we are slowing down
as our velocity gets closer and closer
to zero because the absolute value is
getting closer and closer to zero